can pots go away that's a really
interesting question pots can be put
into remission just like other
autoimmune issues can be put in
remission there are four types of pots
one is autoimmune pots one is adrenergic
pots which is a adrenal kind of pots
related to your adrenals and your
epinephrine epinephrine these people
tend to have high blood pressure and
crazy crazy blood pressure fluctuations
there is neurogenic pots which is
usually the people with the blue feet
and those people tend to have more the
low blood pressure that's chronically
low they feel cold all the time so
there's different kinds of pots and with
these different parts you get different
symptoms but there's a lot of overlap
between these three different kinds